[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur l'ensemble
des chaînes locales et régionales et sur
tv5 monde
nous commençons ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité en demandant à saint-etienne
face à la recrudescence du nombre de cas
de co vide 19 l'état à imposer vous le
savez la fermeture des salles de sport
comme dans onze métropoles de france
d'ailleurs
cette décision a provoqué
l'incompréhension et la colère des
gérants de ces salles comme vous allez
pouvoir le constater dans ce reportage
réalisé à saint-just de saint rambert
par nos confrères de tl7 télé loire 7 à
saint-etienne regarder que ce soit au
niveau économique que ce soit au niveau
de la santé fermé les salles c'est une
décision qui est aberrant
six mois après avoir été contraint au
confinement une soixantaine de gérants
de salles de sport de la loire s'est
rassemblée pour y voir plus clair sur
les raisons qui poussent les autorités à
demander une nouvelle fermeture sur les
territoires de saint-etienne métropole
et du roi on ferme des lieux notamment
des clubs de remise en forme
pourquoi nous d'ailleurs des bars des
restaurants pour
tenter de sauver quelques milliers de
vies le problème c'est que nous on parle
de dizaines de mai aux personnes qui
vont se retrouver dans une situation
économique catastrophique elle ses
gérants ont donc décidé de déposer un
recours devant le tribunal administratif
de lyon pour contester ces fermetures et
pour avoir plus de poids
ils ont invité le député de la loire
régis juanico qui défend les bienfaits
du sport pour lutter contre la copie 19
ils ont aujourd'hui une situation dans
les salles de sport qui fait qu'on n'a
pas de clusters on n'a pas d'aujourd'hui
de cas plus que qu'ailleurs dans la
société et ils sont un peu montrée du
doigt en étant un peu les seules
structures commerciales à être comme sa
ferme et donc ils m'ont demandé d'être
un intermédiaire pour demander un rendez
vous avec la préfète de la loire pour
pouvoir envisager éventuellement un
réaménagement des décisions et si tous
ne sont pas touchés par cette fermeture
les gérants voulait prouver leur bonne
foi et montrer que les règles sanitaires
été respectée dans les salles à la
sortie de la voiture
le masque doit être portée il y à du gel
hydroalcoolique à l'encré que les gens
doivent obligatoirement se mettre quand
ils s'entraînent ils peuvent enlever
leurs masques mais restait aux distances
on va dire obligatoire le matériel
ailleurs usage unique
il est nettoyé à chaque fois qu'il est
utilisé nous notre salle actuellement
elle fait six ans jusqu'à 800 mètres
carrés dont quatorze personnes dont 800
m² est désormais tous ont une crainte
que la fermeture dure beaucoup plus que
15 jours
voilà des mesures et des normes strictes
également dans les universités vous le
savez malgré le nombre de cas en
augmentation les étudiants faisaient
leur rentrée cette semaine
après plusieurs mois sans fac nous
partons dans les hauts de france en
picardie plus précisément où trente
mille étudiants étaient au rendez-vous
et nos confrères de wéo la chaîne de la
voix du nord les ont suivis regardez ce
reportage
une rentrée universitaire sous fond de
crise sanitaire à l'udpci vais les
étudiants dû s'adapter aux
recommandations pour éviter la
propagation du coronavirus port du
masque obligatoire lavage des mains
distanciation les règles sont
visiblement bien appliqué et nicolas en
licence de staps se sent bien protégés
et les étudiants ils arrivent et songe à
masquer dans les locaux à musique
n'importe où dort on oublie ce ton
démasqué donc tout est nickel il ya déjà
les deux recrues qu'un peu partout et
les distances dans les amphis sont
respectés il ya un mètre à chaque fois
quand on rentre c'est tout un côté comme
ça on sait tous de l'eau donc tout à
fait respectueux outre ces gestes
barrières l'université a dû réorganiser
sa manière de dispenser les cours
principal aménagement l'installation de
caméras dans les amphis pour permettre
de capter et enregistrer les cours
magistraux pour pouvoir ensuite les
transmettre en direct les dans une autre
salle où pour le suivi les cours en
distanti l autre adaptation certains
cours qui rassemble un grand nombre
d'étudiants seront scindés en deux une
partie restera en selle et l'autre
suivra le cours à distance de chez elle
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est pour
chaque discipline chaque campus avoir la
meilleure solution par exemple
l'alternance de 50 % d'étudiants c'est
facile dans certains pendant d'autres
la notion de circulation d'étudiants
elle est simple dans certains campus pas
dans d'autres
les travaux pratiques mais seront
présents sienne avec des protections
maximum et après la mise à l'isolément
de deux promotions de médecine suite à
des rassemblements dehors de
l'université
il est également rappelé aux étudiants
d'être vigilant irresponsable quand ils
ne sont pas dans l'enceinte des facultés
occupées givet demande aux associations
est différent b2 et c ra de ne pas
tarder à deux soirées étudiantes nous on
respecte on ne fera pas de soirées
étudiantes pour rentrer l'objectif est
ainsi pour tout le monde d'éviter au
maximum la circulation du virus est le
recours aux distances yale qui pourrait
nuire à la qualité des diplômes cuvée
2020 2021
voilà un vaccin pour le coc vite 19 nous
l'espérons tous et l'espoir pourrait
venir de grenoble de chercheurs
grenoblois précisément qui travaillent
activement dans leur laboratoire de
l'isère sur un vaccin et les équipes de
tv grenoble ont pu les rencontrer pour
nous ils font le point sur leurs
recherches et les espoirs qu'il suscite
regarder
face à la pandémie de covile 19
plusieurs propositions de vaccins sont
actuellement en cours d'évaluation en
france et à l'étranger à grenoble une
nouvelle formule vaccinale a reçu le
soutien du ministère de la recherche et
de l'innovation le fruit d'une
collaboration entre le cea leti et l'iab
et l'institut pour l'avancée des
biosciences de l'inserm et qui repose
sur une technique déjà utilisée dans le
cadre de la recherche vaccinale contre
le vih l'idée de base est d'utiliser des
petites gouttelettes lipidique qui sont
fabrique des lipides naturel donc ces
gouttelettes sont de la taille d'un
virus donc elles sont très petit calibre
et et elles vont être prises en charge
par le système immunitaire comme des
virus
c'est un sorte de leurre et sur ces
gouttelettes il est possible de greffer
des éléments du virus qui permettent
donc de diriger la réponse immunitaire
contre ces éléments là nous fabriquons
les particules au cea leti avec cette
possibilité de les fabriquer de façon
industrielle avec un transfert vers
l'industrie donc et le l'inserm va lui
validé biologiquement et de façon
précliniques des particules cette
technique est innovante elle utiliser
des produits naturels qui facilite la
phase de production ici au coeur du cea
ce candidat-vaccin grenoblois devrait
être accessible pour des essais
cliniques d'ici à fin 2021
le ministère de la recherche et de
l'innovation a soutenu deux autres
candidats vaccins en france à lille et
créteil dans l'actualité également de ce
grand jt des territoires un débat qui va
inviter pour plusieurs années à notre
société
l'installation de la 5g en france donne
lieu vous le savez à de nombreuses levée
de boucliers de la part des élus locaux
notamment la place du numérique sur
notre territoire et la transition au
digital était au menu des assises du
numérique qui se sont tenues dans les
yvelines cette semaine vous allez le
voir dans ce reportage de la chaîne tv
78 ces débats n'ont pas fini d'agiter
les passions regarder comment réussir la
transformation digitale de nos
territoires c'était tout l'objet des
troisièmes assises du numérique
parmi les thèmes abordés licence
tu es la sûreté urbaine
dématérialisation ou encore le numérique
pour l'éducation et cette année ces
sujets ont une résonance particulière
pendant évidemment la crise sanitaire
elle confinement qu'on a connus on a vu
que le numérique prenez vraiment une
place prépondérante dans la vie des
citoyens
la première table ronde était consacrée
au numérique pour l'éducation
raccordement à la fibre très haut débit
ou achat de vidéoprojecteurs interactifs
les établissements opère un tournant et
depuis 2000 15 18 collèges divine
participent à un projet pilote grâce
auquel dix mille élèves et 1000
professeurs ont reçu des tablettes à des
souhait était de travailler le passage
du manuel scolaire papier traditionnel
un ensemble de ressources numériques
dont les manuels scolaires numériques
pourquoi pas cette table ronde était
donc l'occasion entre autres de faire le
bilan de ce projet pilote qui s'achève
cette année pour les élèves la joute
d'appareils numériques comme la tablette
en plus des outils papier semble
bénéfique
le bilan est d'autant plus positif pour
cet établissement qu'élèves et
professeurs ou utiliser la tablette
pendant tout le confinement ça nous a
permis de garder du lien véritablement
avec nos élèves et de continuer un
travail de qualité sap a juste été un
pis-aller
moi je dis souvent aux mains amusant
mais comme on n'avait pas les scories du
quotidien est bien pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans j'ai terminé mon programme
en troisième en lettres au total plus de
400 personnes ont participé à ces
troisièmes assises du numérique
nous partons à présent pour l'occitanie
à la solidarité s'organise envers les
agriculteurs très touché par les
intempéries qui se sont abattues dans
les cévennes il ya près d'une semaine
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage
signé des équipes devient occitanie
c'est toute la profession de la région
qui est venu prêter main forte
un élan de solidarité qui réchauffe bien
le coeur regarder dix jours après
l'épisode cévenol l'heure est à la
reconstruction
gaël martin et producteurs d'oignons
doux dans le gard sur la commune de val
dé galles le 19 septembre
le viala de crouzet qui coule
tranquillement au bord de ces terres
s'est transformé en vagues dévastatrices
c'était un chat noyon se situer à
environ 10 mètres - la terre vers la
terre végétale 10 mètres derrière donc à
plus de terre avait j'étale plus de mur
s'est saisi du terrain
perdu à jamais un à trois millions de
mètres carrés concernés on passe direct
pouvoir récupérer me lisa mètres carrés
mais avec beaucoup de travail pour ce
chantier colossal et l martin peut
compter sur la solidarité agricoles
venus de tout le département du gard des
agriculteurs viennent prêter main forte
à leurs confrères cévenol à l'initiative
des syndicats des jeunes agriculteurs de
la fdsea et de la chambre d'agriculture
plusieurs journées seront organisées
tout au long de l'hiver
il ya quelque chose de naturel qui se
fait chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire
voilà et aussi parce qu on demain ça
peut nous arriver à nous et cet élan a
toujours existé et c'est ce que c'est ce
qui est fantastique dans le monde
agricole
au total l'association de défense de
l'oignon doux des cévennes des nombreux
8 hectares de terres abîmés ou perdus
sur les 55 hectares de production malgré
un bel élan de camaraderie
certaines parcelles sont irrécupérables
la terre fondement de leur métier étant
emportés par les flots
si au niveau 1 au niveau des autorités
on nous aide en nous apporte des z
au niveau financier pour pouvoir
défricher et reconstruire des terrasses
on va y arriver mais si on n'a pas de
moyens financiers mais finalement ça va
être très difficile pour débloquer des
aides financières le conseil gardois
d'agriculture français à demander un
classement en calamité agricole
d'après une première estimation
l'épisode cévenol aurait causé 5
millions d'euros de dégâts agricoles
le grand jt des territoires mettant en
avant cette semaine ceux qui se battent
pour leurs proches pour venir en aide à
leurs proches souffrent et en manque
d'autonomie
on les appelle les aidants et une
caravane qui leur est dédié s'est
installée place de la république à metz
vous allez voir les équipes de via
moselle tv étaient sur place pour les
suivre
christophe gros vent et tes dents depuis
plusieurs années il a réintégré la
maison familiale ce qui a permis le
maintien à domicile de sa maman de 93
ans une situation malgré tout difficile
qui l'a amené à solliciter des aides
comme cette caravane itinérante et les
renseignements sur
l'aide personnalisée à l'autonomie j'ai
monté un dossier
j'ai depuis deux semaines je suis sur
une formation des aidants est déjà en
deux séances j'ai appris des méthodes
qui me permettent de
de faire face à d des paroles à des
situations sans m'énerver ils sont 11
millions d'aidants en france à
accompagner un proche âgées ou en
situation de handicap a les épaules et
au quotidien ou à distance
et parfois il s'agit d'un vrai parcours
du combattant pour connaître leurs
droits
les aides dont ils peuvent bénéficier
pour assumer ce statut si particulier
alors depuis juillet la caravane des
aidants sillonnent les villes de france
pour aller au contact direct de cette
population
elle est à metz jusqu'à mercredi quand
on devient et dans ont recherché des
informations spécifiques sur le
territoire où vit notre proche donc du
coup là on est mis en relation par notre
intermédiaire donc par la compagne et
des aidants avec d'autres aidants c'est
la paire et danse parce que ses autres
aidants ont acquis des compétences en
accompagnant leurs parents
62 % des aidants doivent concilier leur
vie professionnelle et leur rôle
d'aidant en aménageant notamment leur
ton travail
un vrai problème sociétal car en moyenne
elle est dans habitat 226 km de son
proche en ce qui concerne le grand âge
notamment une cause dont se sont
solidaires la municipalité de metz qui a
souhaité accueillir cette caravane
d'avoir des aidants qui supportent jour
et nuit ils parent ou leur mari et c'est
pour ça qu'il est important que la
collectivité que l'état que la société
aide ses aidants qui sont parfois dans
des situations physique mais parfois
psychique
le/la tivement relativement préoccupante
sur chaque étape de la caravane des
assistantes sociales orienter les
aidants en quête d'informations vers les
différents organismes sociaux mais c'est
aussi l'occasion de mettre en relation
les aidants entre eux pour qu'ils
puissent s'échanger des informations et
tisser un réseau d'entr'aide voilà
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires
c'est mickaël tassart le rédacteur en
chef du courrier picard bonjour mickaël
tassart
vous êtes donc le rédacteur en chef de
ce quotidien régional qui appartient au
groupe rossel alors une première
question pour vous comment le courrier
picard votre journal s'est il adapté à
ces temps nouveaux pour les médias tous
ces axes de développement nouveau
comment les avez vous intégré dans votre
stratégie
aujourd'hui comment faites vous
et bien cyrille en fait on s'est aperçu
très vite dès la mi mars
qu'on avait une nette augmentation de
nos audiences sur notre site web
on a appris aussi maintenant à entendre
ce que nos internautes avaient à nous
dire et ça se concrétise très nettement
serre en cette rentrée du mois de
septembre par la création de nouvelle
newsletter pour parler à davantage de
monde encore et puis par la création
d'un site internet dédié aux jeunes
alors justement les actes de
développement numérique par le biais par
exemple d'une newsletter ou par le biais
de vos sites comment faites vous
concrètement pour les mettre en place
c'est absolument indispensable de
répondre à nos lecteurs à quelques
endroits qu'ils se trouvent
cette crise a fait naître d'autres
besoins qu'on avait déjà perçu un bien
avant mais qui se sont nettement
accélérées depuis cet été alors le
courrier picard a été très active durant
la crise sanitaire comment avez-vous
fait avec vos lecteurs pour essayer de
créer du liant avec eux de la proximité
de les aider par exemple on a mis en
place une opération qu'on a appelé un
journal pour un sourire et on a
distribué chaque jour mille exemplaires
du courrier picard on a eu des retours
incroyables de gens qui avaient vraiment
apprécié ce geste là parce que le
journal le média et bien c'était un lien
avec un extérieur auquel il avait plu à
un accès on sait la crise économique
impacte énormément la presse quotidienne
régionale
vous avez lancé des pages spéciales
économie comment sont-elles rédigé quel
est l'axé éditoriale de ces deux cépages
l'économie pour nous on a très vite
considéré que c'est l axe d'attac
important de cette fin d'année donc
notre nouveau cahier échos qui paraît
chaque lundi met l'accent à la fois sur
ces entreprises qui innovent pour se
sortir un peu de cette crise là et met
aussi l'accent beaucoup sur celles qui
recrutent pour mettre en relation les
demandeurs d'emploi et les entreprises
qui cherchent de la main d'oeuvre alors
la question c'est comment la presse
quotidienne régionale comment le
courrier picard peut traiter ces
questions économiques d'une manière
différente des grands quotidiens
économiques nationaux par exemple
comment vous comment vous faites et bien
c'est toujours la même force en fait on
s'appuie sur cette édition locale
qui chaque semaine vont essayer de
trouver l'entreprise qui peut être en
temps normal n'aurait pas eu place dans
nos colonnes là on essayait de prendre
du recul avec ça et d'aller pousser des
portes pour voir comment ces entreprises
elles s'adaptent à cette crise là et ça
quand on est au fin fond de l'aisne et
bien il ya qu un journaliste local pour
aller taper à votre porte
voilà merci michael tu as far d'avoir
été l'invitée du grand jt des
territoires et maintenant c'est
peut-être un sujet pour vous ça regardez
avec new directions les vosges c'est la
rencontre d'une société pour qui tout
roule son nom moustache bike spécialisée
dans le vélo électrique qui vous le
savez est en plein essor l'évolution de
la marque est exponentielle en termes
d'activité de chiffre d'affaires aussi
et de recrutement une très belle
histoire que nous raconte nos confrères
devient vous regardez
ce logo est bien connue et pas seulement
dans les vosges on prend aujourd'hui des
nouvelles de l'entreprise moustache bike
qui se porte à merveille depuis sa
création en 2011 mais dont l'évolution
est exponentielle depuis quelques mois
déjà à la gagner un peu de place pour
ses unités de production exit les 3500
m² des anciens locaux devenus trop
exigus à golbey et direction cap avenir
vosges pour s'étendre sur cette fois dix
mille mètres carrés évolution du nombre
de salariés est également passé de 100 à
140 en quelques mois l'évolution enfin
du chiffre d'affaires qui s'était déjà
62 millions d'euros en 2019
l'objectif est d'atteindre les 90
millions cette année bref on peut dire
en effet que la marque de vélos
électriques premium se porte plutôt bien
on vit une croissance quelqu un homme
extrêmement forte depuis 10 ans on a
démarré à deux on est aujourd'hui 140
jacques lavoie là et gestion de la
croissance ça fait partie de notre
boulot au quotidien ce qu'il faut c'est
garder cette croissance sous contrôle
c'est à dire prendre des risques mais
pas trop au point de mettre l'entreprise
en difficulté donc c'est toujours un jeu
d'équilibré du quotidien on avait fait
un choix dès le départ de d'être un
certain niveau de qualité au niveau
moteur batterie cadres etc
donc ça nous positionne à un certain
niveau est ce qu'ils essaient finalement
ces choix là qui nous ont permis
d'évoluer c'est le marché d'ailleurs qu'
au niveau européen a le plus évolué on
est passé de peut-être d'achat coup de
coeur on pourra toujours réfléchi à un
réinvestissement donc les gens
aujourd'hui avec lui dans un produit qui
est durable
aujourd'hui moustache bike est le leader
français dans sa gamme c'est aussi un
acteur qui compte en europe et le marché
est grand ouvert la crise sanitaire a
aussi joué son rôle dans l'évolution de
l'entreprise
tout s'est accéléré depuis le début de
cette année on a eu tous très peur en
début de confinement avec ce manque de
visibilité on ne savait pas combien de
temps allait durer cette période tous
vos magasins revendeurs étaient fermées
donc tout s'est accéléré en inter on a
recruté près de 40 collaborateurs en six
mois il a fait le con comprimés aux
productions pour monter en capacité on
est aujourd'hui sur un rythme de 300
vélos jours en effet tous les feux sont
au vert pour le développement et la
pérennité des vélos moustache une marque
qui a vu le jour dans les vosges qui
s'est développée dans les vosges et qui
si l'on en croit ses cofondateurs
restera dans les bouches
voilà vous en avez entendu parler dans
l'actualité ces derniers temps cette
fois ci cette histoire nous vient de la
sarthe
voici des propriétaires bien embêté ils
ne peuvent plus rentrer dans leurs
maisons leurs immeubles du quartier
washington au mans est squattée depuis
plus de deux mois
leur fils a bien essayé de résoudre le
problème à l'amiable mais il se heurte à
l'inflexibilité de l'occupant illégal et
la loi vous le savez le protège seul
motif d'espoir une nouvelle mesure pour
expulser les squatters des résidences
secondaires c'est un reportage d'anthony
python pour vyas lmt les sartre sur
place regarde un pots de géraniums est
installée à la fenêtre alors que la
maison est censé être en travaux
et pour cause un squatteur a pris
possession des lieux
le fils des propriétaires a tenté
d'instaurer le dialogue avec lui pour
récupérer le bien il dit voilà vous
voulez que je sois parti avant cette
semaine
cette semaine c'est hors de question
rendez vous au tribunal
abruti quoi donc voilà effectivement un
dialogue impossible alors que je pense
que je suis quelqu'un de conciliant et
que voilà je peux comprendre les
difficultés des gens les serrures ont
été changées sans possibilité de rentrer
dans la maison si mon cousin
s'inquiètent des possibles dégradations
je sais que donc il ya une douche de
fortune installés
donc dans une pièce attenante la cuisine
donc appelé pseudo véranda qui n'est pas
du tout fait pour ça donc je me demande
mais voilà est-ce qu'il ya eu des
tournants des des tuyaux de détourner ou
est ce que va l'eau qui s'écoule enfin
jeu oui j'ai peur de retrouver la maison
dans un état délabré
le fils des propriétaires est amer car
la loi est plutôt protectrice des
occupants illégaux pour que la police
intervienne lors du squat d'une
résidence secondaire
la victime doit agir moins de 48 heures
après l'effraction
le fait de rentrer et bien sûr que c'est
un délit au niveau du squat mais c'est
surtout le fait d'y rester et je pense
que chaque jour qui passe en fait c'est
un petit peu comme si le délit se
perpétuer et on voit un délit qui est en
cours sur lequel la justice ne nous suit
pas seul espoir de simon cousin pour
récupérer rapidement la maison un
amendement qui squattent adopté le 17
septembre dernier
il prévoit qu'une résidence secondaire
sera désormais également reconnu comme
domicile le propriétaire peut saisir le
préfet qui peut mettre en demeure le
squatteurs de quitter les lieux
pour la direction la bretagne maintenant
pour un baptême controversé celui de ce
conte bruce dernier né des chalutiers de
france pélagiques qui continue de faire
beaucoup de remous sur place notamment à
concarneau où plus de 200 opposants aux
navires de 81 m capable de pêcher 200
tonnes de poissons en une nuit ne passe
pas du tout sur place tenus à distance
opposant écologistes élus et militants
donner de la voix et n'ont pas hésité à
se mettre à nu pour se faire entendre
vous allez le voir reportage sur les
quais de la ville bleus de christophe
bouchet pour la chaîne tébéo la chaîne
du télégramme en bretagne rarement une
inauguration de bateau aura soulevé un
tel vent de contestation malgré
l'interdiction de manifester 200
personnes étaient présentes et seule une
poignée de marins défendre est une pêche
industrielle éloignée des pratiques
artisanales des bateaux les rues je
travaille en flottille alors après la
guerre quand ils ont commencé à donner à
manger aux gens à donner à manger aux
gens ce ce bateau là qu'est ce qui fait
testify pas fait il avait fait du mal de
lui sa charge
quelle nouvelle ça charrie va céder
africaine au cse comme ça parce qu'ils
crèvent de faim que c'est où ils ont
failli
à bonne distance de l'inauguration
malgré l'interdiction une contre
manifestation se déroulait les
associations blum ou plein air qui
défendent une pêche durable se mettait à
nu pour protester contre un modèle qui
aurait en bloc tous ceux restés sans
rien à manger fut même un péché on nous
nous volent nos quotas on nous vole un
travail et on ne laisse en rien en creux
le modèle hollandais symbole d'une pêche
industrielle est pointé du doigt
mais vraiment ça ça fait le choix d'être
industriel ultra puissante et qu'il ya
vraiment un impact colossal sur négatif
d'un sur sur la ressource mais sur les
emplois la vigueur de nos côtes arrivées
mercredi inauguré ce vendredi le scond
bruce prend la mer dimanche pour
certainement ne jamais revenir à
concarneau
voilà loin de l'agitation de ce
chalutier nous restons en bretagne nous
partons maintenant pour aller regarder
des traditions du côté de l'île et
vilaine
cette fois nous avons à la rencontre de
l'un des dernier sabotier de la région
c'est une sabotière d'ailleurs elle
s'appelle ghislaine levacher elle est
aux commandes de la tradition familiale
fondée par son grand-père en 1938
son portrait avec les équipes de tvr la
chaîne de regarder des sabots avec des
épis de blé
c'est la marque de fabrique de la
famille levacher depuis 1938
ghislaine est désormais aux commandes de
la tradition familiale fondée par son
grand-père un savoir faire qu'elle ne
voulait pas voir disparaître ou voulons
pas le savoir faire s'il avait plus
personne après c'était fini depuis tout
petit je vais donc tout en était là
quand il faisait ici
ranger la cieux donc j'ai des ballons il
faut pas laisser un savoir faire partir
comme ça en tout il faut une dizaine
d'étapes pour réaliser un sabot est un
peu plus de trois heures de travail une
partie est très physique le creusage il
s'agit de vider l'intérieur de la
chaussure le tout avec les d'une machine
et la cuillère et creuse l'intérieur de
mon savoir et donc ça avec ma manette
le mouvement de démouville ans que je
fais avancer macreuse depuis une
vingtaine d'années ghislaine a
diversifié son activité elle réalise
différents types de sabots ou dérivés et
surtout des chaussures avec des semelles
en bois un produit qui séduit une
nouvelle clientèle notamment en période
estivale
j'ai beaucoup de jeunes qui reviennent
se sont vu leurs grands-parents porter
les sabots est assez vrai c'était hyper
pratique on va au jardin on allait les
chansons dedans on les sabres ont fait
de la porte on rentre dans la maison et
confond son ex au point compté entre 25
et 90 euros pour vous procurer une des
paires fabriqués par ghislaine
directement en boutique ouvert son site
internet sa clientèle vient de toute la
france pour acheter ses sabots voilà
merci d'avoir suivi le grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tmp
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au courage à tous au
revoir
[Musique]